the morale of the prodigy is as classic
as horror movies go it would be this
creepy kids sure are creepy but lurking
under the surface of this tale of
alarming and unsettling offspring is a
deeper story of a mother's love and the
child's role in the world so maybe you
stuck with a prodigy to its sadistic end
or maybe you are too shocked by the
sight of all that stomach blood to
follow the final twist well get ready
because we've got some major spoilers
ahead let's dig back through the ending
of The Prodigy to figure out what it all
really meant even though the movie takes
a while to build up to the full reveal
the main premise of The Prodigy is laid
out right in the beginning a series of
spliced scenes reveal a police task
force raiding the compound of a
mysterious serial killer at the exact
time a woman named Sarah played by
Taylor Schilling gives birth to a baby
boy in a hospital as soon as a man is
shot to death the infant pops out this
scene introduces audiences to the
building blocks that this movie is
constructed on but more than that it
also lubricates the audience's minds to
the bizarre concepts of reincarnation
and so transfer that come into play to
walsim movies and by giving away the big
reveal before the opening credits even
finished The Prodigy has plenty of room
to play with those ideas without putting
the brakes on the story to explain how
all this happened we already know
there's a serial killer soul living in
miles he's gonna do bad things you know
just like Chucky
but with a real boy instead
I hate kids The Prodigy leans heavily on
this important idea of reincarnation
when you die you come back to life in
another body but in this movie world the
process is sort of like a ghost haunting
an old house that mean old spirit is
only sticking around because it left
behind some unfinished business
but the prodigies plot points draw from
more than mystical gurus and religious
beliefs the DVD that reincarnation
maestro arthur jacobson gives to sarah
in the film also comes from a real news
investigation into a boy who claimed to
be a reincarnated world war two pilots i
can meet the japanese easy as pie
clearly the idea was to present all of
these far-fetched themes as offshoots of
the real world anchoring myles
predicaments and his eventual outcome
within the realm of real-life
possibility yeah anyway so let's talk
about miles the titular prodigy and
solid proof that kids should never do
their own halloween makeup this is a boy
with two souls inside him both acting on
his psyche at any given time it turns
out that it's not actually a prodigy
after all all those special smarts a
courtesy of Edward Sokka the crazy man
who died at the beginning of the movie
the movie plays of this duality
constantly from the heterochromia that
gives miles two different colored eyes
to scenes with miles face halfway
obscured by shadow we're given no
opportunity to forget that there's a
killer in there the most iconic moment
comes when miles is eight years old and
wipes off one half of his skeleton
Halloween makeup staring into the mirror
he sees half of a normal boy's face and
half of a twisted skeletons with an
unhealthy interest in ladies hands it's
around this time that Sarkis mine starts
entirely consuming the boy leading him
to commit some pretty vicious acts
what did she do as The Prodigy answers
its final act it does eventually stick a
concrete direction once Sara accepts the
fact that miles is possessed by another
dude soul her working theory is that
Sarkar has some unfinished business that
led him to stick around the land of the
living after his own death and when she
finds my Osaka stash of reading material
in miles bedroom she knows what that
business is
Sokka needs to kill Margaret st. James
played by Brittany Alan you may remember
her as a young woman who got away from
him and led the police to his house in
the opening scenes of the film Sara
decides to help Sokka finish the job
reasoning not doing so will free his
soul and cause him to leave miles once
and for all so Sara buys a gun and takes
her possession on a road trip to the
faraway land of Ohio intent on
confronting st. James at her house with
this decision
The Prodigy veers out of bad seed
territory and takes us down a new path
this isn't a family trying to survive
that evil progeny this is a mother who
will stop at nothing to protect her son
even if it means shooting an innocent
woman the internal conflict Sara faces
as she contemplates shooting Margaret
st. James is compounded by a shocking
revelation margaret herself also has
children by shooting her Sara would only
save her own son of the expense of
another mother like Miles Halloween
pains the movie introduces us mirrored
circumstance put the help of a literal
mirror Sara loads a gun in Margaret's
bathroom only to come face-to-face with
her reflection she realizes that in a
way she'll be destroying the life of
someone very much like herself in an
effort to prevent the destruction of her
own in the end a Sara can't do it she
drops the gun on the kitchen table and
accepts defeat
that is until miles walks into the
kitchen with a big knife and plunges it
into Margaret st. James finishing the
job that Sokka started years earlier in
the woods of Ohio my loss isn't a kid
you won in the backseat of your car and
Sara knows this earlier in the movie the
boy stabbed his dad with a big pair of
garden scissors that's the kind of thing
that would totally ruin Sara's plan so
before she starts the long drive to see
Margaret st. James
she gives miles a motion sickness pill
that will put him to sleep and thwart
any unexpected stabbings it's big really
for your little traveler Dramamine for
kids it appears to work when they
finally arrive at st. James's house
miles are still fast asleep
giving Sara time to take care of the
business without his interference and
fortunately she forgot the foreshadowing
provided by Arthur Jacobson earlier in
the film Sokka is really really good at
pretending to be asleep he literally
said those words out loud it just days
before Sara tried to drug miles to sleep
of course the boys awake yet dingus he's
possessed by an evil fake sleeping
genius
so when Myles suddenly shows up in the
kitchen it's because Sokka was in
control the whole time waiting patiently
until the right moment to strike and it
isn't long before we find out how much
control he actually has at this point in
the prodigy two things are clear Sokka
is more powerful than we realized
and Sara is kind of a terrible mom put
them together and the plan that's been
unfolding in secret this whole time
suddenly comes to light everything that
sara has been doing to help her son
kicking her husband out of the house
driving to Ohio trying to kill st. James
has all been carefully orchestrated by
Sokka why well soccer really does want
to kill Margaret st. James like Sara
gasps but he's stuck in the body of a
minor
he can't just hop in a car and drive
there himself to that end
he's been subtly manipulating Sara from
the start remember when Sara learns
about Edwards soccer on a laptop at
night and miles lurking in the next room
Sara wasn't coming closer to stopping
Sacco of that knowledge as audiences
were led to believe Sacco was letting
her discover the awful truth on purpose
those breadcrumbs run through the entire
film a baseboard is just so carefully
left to skew leading Sara to discover a
hidden stash of information on st. James
as her most vulnerable moments miles
surfaces as a scared innocent boy
stringing Sara along with the hope that
she still has a chance to fix him in the
film's final twist we realized that
killing st. James wasn't the miracle
cure sara had been hoping for Sarka
still in control of miles body and he's
not planning on going anywhere anytime
soon after manipulating Sara into taking
him to st. James Sokka now has another
problem on his hands Sara with John on
life-support in the hospital and
Jacobson cowered into silence
sara is a
person who could threaten his new life
she's gotta go ever manipulative Sarka
bait sir with the truth miles is gone
she's too late in fact he claims a miles
hasn't been part of the equation since
at least the halfway point of the movie
all of Jacobson's talk about a war
between souls really meant nothing
because Sarka already destroyed the part
of him that was miles Sara takes the
bait threatening her some of the same
gun should plan to use on st. James it
went sort of down like this except she
goes through with it because all that
ruckus draws the attention of a farmer
who shoots Sara before she can pull the
trigger once again Sara is too late the
final moments of the film see young
miles being dropped off with his new
foster family all innocent and smiles
the boy steps out of the car to greet
his new mom and dad in one last scene
before the screen cuts to black we see
miles in his bedroom with old man soccer
looking back at him from his reflection
in the mirror because ambiguity is for
suckers
the message is clear Sokka is free to
kill again
and again even better he's not a lumpy
old man anymore he's a young boy who can
manipulate anyone with his sweetness
making him the ultimate wolf in sheep's
clothing but while that's the ending we
see is it really the ending a various
times throughout the movie Myles managed
to exert some control over soccer most
notably he did this when he was being
hypnotized by Arthur Jacobson
although Sarkis seemingly had total
control in that scene Myles still
managed to scratch a legible message
into a leather couch with justice
fingernails that's not an easy thing to
do and it suggests a Myles mind may
still be a bigger presence and Sokka is
willing to admit maybe even bigger than
soccer realizes after finishing off his
final victim socket cells Sarah and no
in certain terms her little boy is gone
forever
Myles hasn't actually been in there for
a while doesn't even try to let it down
easy after all that she did for him
real mature soccer all right I'm sure
that we can handle this situation
maturely just like the responsible adult
that we are isn't that right mr. puppy
paths but hold on because lies come in
many forms throughout the prodigy
Jacobson also made it clear that soccer
is a masterful liar and a genius
manipulator so who's to say where his
lies actually end well he admit to Sarah
that part of miles are still alive in
there somewhere
not if he wanted her to wave a gun at
him so that hero farmer would step in it
pretend to have full control over the
boy's body but does he really it's
entirely possible that Myles are still
in there somehow and he's still capable
of coming back and stopping soccer in
the future with a movie like this
anything's possible whether it makes
sense or not
check out one of our newest videos right
here Plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]